oui ou non ça prend pas à oui j'adore
c'est magnifique j -1 donc hommage à des
amoureux qui vivent et qui travaillent
ensemble ce n'est pas toujours évident
voilà l'exemple aujourd'hui très réussie
de darry cowl et de sa femme
roland dominique reportage plutôt fait
je suis troublé dominique barrau chez
bernard connor darry cowl a lâché le
triporteur qui l'a rendu célèbre aussi
les mains pour le scooter le pilote sa
part exposé que j'ai fait confiance et
aude espère aussi 44 ans après rolande
calice souvient de leur première
rencontre au théâtre pas vraiment le
coup de foudre mentale l'imperméable
cradingue moi j'étais mariée est 4ème au
prince charmant je suis rentré il m'a
fait la cour échéant rentrer chez moi et
j'ai dit j'ai rencontré un mec marrant
mais c'est pas possible ce mec
pourtant dès leur seconde de rencontre
ils se marient depuis ils ne se lâchent
plus la main dans la vie comme sur les
planches de ces complicités là
la liste est longue
c'est venu jouer moi c'est sur une scène
de théâtre après des choses autre que
votre vie privée
on sort de notre vie privée donc être à
présent d'autres choses
on est prêt les autres c'est chouette
moi j'aime bien
j'aime bien tout ça j aime bien être
près d'elle seule la folie du jeu a
failli les séparer darry cowl y
dilapider sa fortune
rolande a été intraitable elle ou le
tripot aujourd'hui ils trichent toujours
mais en privé ses bêtes des années de
vie commune n'y ont rien changé
le couple est toujours prêt à partir
pour la prochaine aventure